2,8 maintenant on voit cinq heures dans
son culte
et on va revenir sur une interview
d'emmanuel macro hier au jt tracteurs de
bout de gilles bouleau alors il a fait
six millions et demi alors ouais
l'entretien a duré entre 20h12 et 20h40
sa affiche 6 3 millions de
téléspectateurs soit un écart quand même
d'un million trois cent mille par
rapport à son principal concurrent
sachant que la moyenne du jt et à 5
millions 600 mille exactement alors
c'est un score en hausse par rapport à
l'audience moyenne habituelle des jt tf1
on vous a fait un petit récapitulatif et
à jacques séguéla est également virginie
legay qui est chef adjointe du service
politique de paris match qui viennent
nous rejoindre et vous allez voir on a
des très bons trucs sur ça c'est parti à
rire
hier soir vous étiez tous devant tp mp
oui
du coup vous avez pu regarder
l'interview du président n'ont pas de
panique voici le récap soir monsieur le
président bonsoir 28 minutes c'est la
durée de cette interview où tous les
sujets du moment ont été abordés de
donald trump au gilet jaune un entretien
en direct d'un lieu très symbolique nous
sommes ici à bord du charles de gaulle
en mer tout le gros bruit de fond qu'on
a entendu pendant toute l'interview
à part ça gilles bouleau n'a pas pu en
placer une c'est notre allié historique
et le continuera de l'être celle allié
avec lequel on prend tous les risques
aucun changement au monde du logement
social ne demandait aucun changement
on ne vient pas corriger les résultats
de ce qui ne marche pas mais on vient de
corriger à la racine faut les
accompagner
c'est ce que le premier ministre a
annoncé ce matin et emmanuel macron à 10
57 fois ça et donc et donc et donc et
donc et donc et donc et donc et donc et
donc et donc côté audiences les
téléspectateurs étaient 6 millions 300
mille devant l'interview du président
hier soir alors selon vous le président
macron at-il été bon
[Musique]
merci house à arusha et toutes les
équipes ont préparé sujet merci à
jacques séguéla de biens devenus nous
rejoindre merci jacques séguéla bien sûr
qu'on ne présente plus expert en
communication du sitac date la ville dès
lé chef adjoint du service politique de
paris match à littry souriante et très
sympathique je suis très contente de la
voir
merci d'être là virginie et on va
revenir donc chose qui s'est passé hier
alors vous vient de vous faire un résumé
de ce qui s'est passé et la dernière
fois qu emmanuel macron s'était exprimé
sur le service public c'était en
décembre 2007 2017 sur france 2 bien sûr
avec laurent delahousse et c'était plus
une balade qu'une interview ça avait été
beaucoup décrié vous rappeler de ça le
soupçon général auriez-vous soul
influence du pouvoir de l'argent de la
finance des grandes entreprises cet
amour sac et sous-entend oui mais les
sous-entendus c'est toujours très
mauvais et on sert à ce moment là les
intérêts des plus sournois ou des
extrêmes il faut être très clair
d'abord ça fait un peu bourget
réchauffer je vous le dis franchement
quand on a quelque chose à dire aux
français quand on a un projet on le dit
et on est positif moi je ne perds pas la
moitié ou le tiers de mon temps dans des
dents mais rassemblement à invectiver
les autres candidats quand on a un
projet pour le pays
on le porte on exprime ou l'expliquent
et c'est ça qui va construire les cinq
prochaines années ce ne sont pas les
invectives ou le soupçon alors ça
c'était sa dernière intervention avec
laurent delahousse celle là c'est la
déambulation à l'elysée on sait ça
exactement six adhérents but reste quand
il était candidat
mais ça voilà ils ont raison mais voilà
c'était celle-là mais j'essaie celle
qu'on vous laisse t on oui marché et au
régime vous verrez vous travers un jour
à sion des ambulances avaient 5 millions
7 et sur tf1 ça avait cartonné son
macron 7 millions un pic à 8 millions
exactement que c'est vrai ça va mieux au
marché alors l'échelle juste moi endroit
gardons et on pourrait dire on pourrait
souligner l'incroyable transformation
physique
cette période louis s'exprime et la
période d'aujourd'hui et voir à quel
point le pouvoir politique est quelque
chose d'assez chant et de voilà que
nicolas sarkozy c'est un peu pareil au
départ est vrai c'est vrai que dès que
au bout de deux ans voilà deux demandes
armes on avait vu n'avait vraiment il
avait pris après françois hollande le
deux ans de mandat frère il a vécu
françois hollande à l'elysée il a déçu
président frère toute la journée la paix
le room-service ahmed mois des boulettes
fin m'en fous je suis président ramène
moi le mot que tu veux mon show alors
excuse moi il reste il reste pas du baby
beel un truc d'échangés pro je prends
obasi des annonces étaient ils étaient
démontés alors est ce que vous savez où
justement on parle d'eau durant lequel
est l'homme politique qui a fait le plus
d'audience lors d'une intervention au jt
de 20h on dit là alors dites moi avoue
sarkozy je dirais sarkozy vous devez
vous dites quoi non dsk 13 millions cinq
veaux légers retards chirac
vous n'êtes est-ce qu'un alors on va
voir leur numéro en numéro 3 00 numéro
trois c'est nicolas sarkozy 12,1
millions nicolas sarkozy c'était le 29
novembre 2007 en deuxième position ne
l'avait pas dit c'est dominique de
villepin avec 13,3 millions de
téléspectateurs on s'en rappelle et
c'est vrai que celui qui a fait le plus
d'audience sur les hommes politiques et
ça parlait pas de politique justement
c'est dominique strauss kahn à
l'inventeur de tf1 13,4 millions de
téléspectateurs 4 47% parts de marché
c'est-à-dire 47 % des gens qui
regardaient la télé une personne sur
deux regarder le jt de tf1 rappelez vous
c'était dominique strauss kahn et ses
six des huits qu'a fait le plus
d'audience sur un jt de 20 heures
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce qui
s'est passé ne comprend ni violence ni
contrainte ni agression ni aucun acte
délictueux c'est le procureur qui le dit
ce n'est pas moi ce qui s'est passé
était une relation non seulement
inappropriée mais plus que ça une faute
et on ne s'en lasse pas on le revoit
améliorer on est tous arrivé on dirait
que ça suffit maintenant
saissac incroyable ils étaient tous en
train de regarder alors thomas l'adulent
voir plein de fois tout le monde l'a vu
mais on était tous captivé alors on va
maintenant parler du président macron
est ce qu'il a été bon hier soir sur tf1
c'était une intervention qui était très
importante avant bien sûr les événements
du 17 novembre puisque on parie sur un
blocage de la france alors on va d'abord
revenir sur le lieu de l'interview
c'était sur le porte avions charles de
gaulle
pourquoi à votre avis la choisi ce lieu
est ce que vous savez jacques séguéla où
il ya un grand problème dans cette
émission c'est que elle était prévu
plusieurs mois à l'avancé
ouais comme fin de la série de
l'itinérance un courriel qui est un
titre stupide il fallait dire les
chemins de la mémoire pourquoi elle
passe d'être simple et qui a commencé
déjà un peu mal tourné parce que macro a
été rattrapé par l'actualité qui était
l'essence et se sont mélangés les poilus
et les poids lours de choses qui n'ont
pas tellement ensemble et ça a été la
même chose hier où l'émission était
prévu uniquement sur le régalien sur le
chef des armées sur après le temps de la
paix les armes pour garder la paix et il
a conquis compte tenu du poids une fois
de plus de l'actualité il a été obligé
de parler et de la paix mais surtout de
l'essor alors justement c'était donc sur
le porte avions charles de gaulle et il
ya eu des gros gros problème de son vrai
qu'on vienne sur ça
c'était incroyable les problèmes de son
on a entendu que des bruits chelou
pendant toute l'interview
regardez par exemple on a eu un premier
bruit show l'oust et celui-là il c'est à
vous donc pour l'interview du président
bonsoir monsieur le président bonsoir de
la place de la france dans le monde et
ce porte avions est un symbole
je ne vais pas me mettre à faire un
débat avec le président des états unis
d'amérique avec qui j'ai passé plus de
trois heures en tête à tête
c'est un vaste programme
mais il requiert la mobilisation de
toute la nation c'est le président de la
république c'est le gouvernement c'est
la nation toute entière et j'aurai
besoin de vous tous merci à vous julien
arnaud c'est tabou sur la terre ferme
alors c'est incroyable parce qu'elle est
à la fois il y avait eu la lumière n ya
pas un mec là bas qu'ici les mecs je
suis le problème mais c'est rien c'est
pas un truc de ouf on entend quand même
une machine à laver et un derrière oui
oui le charles de gaulle un avis un
navire opérationnel un habile de navires
de guerre qui ont mis sur de guerre au
moment où il a servi aussi à nadia ne
s'arrête jamais sauf quand le cac
voilà et donc pour que le il soit perçue
est obligé de naviguer face au vent à
pleine puissance pour que les avions
puissent affronter le plus lentement
possible qu'ils sont qui sont obligés de
mettre les moteurs à pleine puissance
donnera pas l'arrêter en pleine mer m
l'autre comme ça ça c'est incroyable
airs de guerre donc le bruit sera c'est
toute l'année comme ça alors rien alors
bien sûr pourrait pour faire une bonne
terre nous faut être deux on va revenir
là dessus et c'était gilles bouleau qui
avait été choisi pour interviewer
emmanuel macron est ce que vous l'avez
trouvé bon avant de parler de la
prestation des manuels macron regarder
le style gilles bouleau bonsoir monsieur
le président bonsoir merci de nous
accueillir nous sommes ici à bord du
charles de gaulle en mer il ya quelques
jours vous disiez dans une interview il
faut bâtir une armée auriel rapidement
parce que des puissances qui peuvent
déstabiliser la paix mondiale sont
autour de nous que dites-vous en un mot
à ces personnes à ses citoyens français
c'est gilet jaune qui ont intention de
bloquer vouloir dit on va faire donner
la maréchaussée et crs comme disait
charles de gaulle dont ce porte-avions
porte le nom vaste programme merci à
leurs yeux de dizaines mais tu retrouves
sur crois qu'il le disait sur autres je
ne veux pas me ranger dans sa médiation
y beaucoup c'est un vaste programme
c'est la nation toute entière et j'aurai
besoin de vous tous
merci à vous julien arnaud c'est à vous
sur la terre ferme gilles bouleau est ce
qu'il était bon j'arrête moi d'abord
j'ai pas aimé le décor j'ai trouvé ça
régale quirion ouais mais je trouve que
ces gadgets en fait sauf que c'est de la
mise en scène et je trouve qu'on n'a pas
besoin de ça quand on est
téléspectateurs et qu'on attend les
réponses sur le pouvoir d'achat la
sécurité le chômage
je trouve que c'est un gadget essai de
la cosmétique et moi ça me sort
complètement de du sujet voilà donc déjà
ça c'est pas c'est pas le surgé boulot
gilles bouleau il a été bon dans le
temps imparti
je trouve qu'il a été un bon petit
soldat il a dit qu'il veut une lettre de
porte parole des français
moi j'ai trouvé un petit peu quand même
mouton un petit peu sage et pas assez
agressif et pas assez teigneux alors
raymond kéké vraiment pour moi c c c
voilà c'est un peu on a toujours un peu
le même avis raymond mine de rien c'est
avec raymond vall a été chauffeur
livreur était surtout bon pote rêvons
question à penser j'ai trouvé très sage
et le boulot même dans ces questions
j'ai trouvé très sage il lève le doigt
pour parler et emmanuel margouty chaîne
en chaîne en chaîne et il ne laisse pas
parler après sur l'histoire du
porte-avions je pense qu'il s'est mis
dans son confort parce qu'on a vu ici ya
pas très longtemps il ya plein de
conflit en france qui sont en train de
sortir de partons avec les ambulanciers
là il y avait 200 personnes qui ont
manifesté mais je pense que s'ils font
ça à la tour tf1
il ya du monde qui les attend à un tronc
tf1 donc là il sert danse ça ça n'a rien
à voir
je sais que c'est c'est emmanuel macron
qu'il admirait puisque tous les
présidents est là et fait un pas hier
françois hollande été tués à bord ont
été président nicolas sarkozy bien sûr
jacques chirac
donc voila c'était une demande de
l'elysée et du président sortant par la
bonne période
alors gilles bouleau a été très bon mais
pour une seule raison une simple raison
c'est que c'est la première fois qu'on a
moi j'adore surprise donc jeu très très
moderne dans la forme c'est la première
fois qu'on peut avoir une relance avec
le président que c'est des vrais
interview tout ce qui était fait avant
sur arlette chabot face à face à jacques
chirac
elle été mis de côté paris match face à
sarkozy mis de côté tous ceux qui aux
états et la compta question voilà les
contredire un président ce n'était pas
une question d une réponse passe à autre
chose
été mis de côté ou été sanctionné on a
enfin enfin des vrais interviews et ça
c'est grâce à lui notamment
est ce que vous avez trouvé bon octobre
à s'auto moi j'ai trouvé que il
j'ai besoin de voir un chef de l'état
qui voulait renouer qui comprenait qu'il
y avait un truc cassé entre les français
et lui et de ce point de vue là est une
forme de mea culpa il reconnaît
certaines choses c'est après parce que
je comprends pas c'est la séquence
global combat il fait il fait europa ya
dix jours il fait 15 minutes sur cette
fois nord vendredi dernier où jeudi
dernier la il fait 20 minutes
je trouve que trop de paroles tu la
parole d'air chaud que l'audience est
pas honnêtement ce n'est pas
impressionnant pour un gérant de l'état
je serais pour nathan wynn et moi je
voudrais juste une chose c'est qu'un
jour le chef de l'état emmanuel macron
ils viennent ils avaient un problème de
lumière l'autre fois à l'elysée des
épreuves de sombres qui viennent nous
voir sur france 2 frêche pour sa
paroisse à l'avant avec léa salamé avec
anne sophie lapix et qu'on ait le temps
en fait c'est ce qui est embêtant c'est
qu'on a quand on est dans des interviews
êtes énervé qu'il est encore chaud du
téléphone oui ces divisions positionner
sur cette année mais attendez tous les
journaux se positionne en permanence
prochaine comporte 24 et là moi je dis
on a fait on a fait le job on leur a
fait des propositions pas s'ils veulent
pas venir je sais pas peut-être qu'ils
ont mais pourquoi il vient pas vous
hâter d'arrêt pour france télévisions
puisque normalement cette raison qu'il
faut leur demander c'est je ne sais pas
d'accord je ne sais pas il encore chez
tf1
mais alors justement va revenir sur les
grands moments des manuels macouin 20h12
il est revenue sur les tweets de donald
trump qui ont fait beaucoup parler
regarder entre alliés on se doit le
respect et donc je ne veux pas entendre
le reste et je crois que ce que les
françaises et les français attendent de
moi
c'est de ne pas répondre à des tweets
mais c'est de ma tâche est justement à
ce que nous coûte nous continuons cette
histoire importante
alors ça c'est sûr donne un truc comme
vous l'avez trouvé où le président
franchement virginie
franchement c'est le problème avec les
intérêts qui sont prévues longtemps à
l'avant dans des cadres qui sont prévues
longtemps à l'avancé classe a tombé
comme un cheveu sur la soupe le décor
n'avait rien à voir avec l'actualité
il a été obligé de répondre à beaucoup
de questions qui se posaient d'actualité
et en plus y avait ce bruit de
soufflerie qui a achevé à mon avis de
brouiller tous les messages
ce qui fait que mon amour l'écoutant
très attentivement pendant 20 minutes on
pouvait trouver que son intervention sur
le fond était intelligente la pédagogie
de l'impôt ce qu'il a expliqué emmanuel
macron est à présent la république
intelligent donc là dessus on n'a pas
été déçu mais sur le but qui était de
convaincre les français qui veulent se
retrouver dimanche samedi pardon 17
novembre dans la rue là je crois que
c'était trop peu trop tard trop
compliqué et beaucoup trop de messages à
la fois une abondance de parole
justement la nuit à la chose essentielle
qui était que répond le président de la
république à la colère des français
le français va justement la colère de
certains français parce que c'est
certain français justement dans
l'extrait regard des sujets bien là il y
a beaucoup de gens qui sont dans
l'addition des colères et l'addition des
blocages
ça ne fait pas un sujet pour le pays un
mot sur le plan garde d'un seul bloc
corps dans un côté vous avez ensemble
des gens qui veulent plus d'emplois
publics et des gens qui veulent moins
d'impôts je dis juste aux français on
est en train de vous mentir il à vous
manipuler
alors alors oui très vite moi je l'adoré
sur l'autocritique et je me suis bien le
regardant hier soir va demain les gens
vont souligner ça et j'ai fait surtout
il ce matin dans la presse dans les
quotidiens et sur les radios de voir que
ça avait fait complètement chou blanc
effectivement donc je rejoins
entièrement nos camarades de paris match
c'est dommage le message est minimale
m'embrouiller virginie virginie jacques
séguéla quand vous l'avez trouvée moi
j'ai trouvé que continue la difficulté
du moment parce que tout ce qu'ils
disent se retourne contre lui c'est la
vague les 3 l on lèche et dieu sait que
les médias l'ont léché mais à n'en plus
finir
deuxièmement on lynche et troisièmement
on lâche et lui il est pile entre le
linge et le lâche et donc ce n'était pas
facile
mais je pense c'est une émission un peu
car tu assistes qui l'a révélé pour la
première fois c'est peut-être le vrai
emmanuel macron qui parle lorsque
hauteur de temps présidentialité mais
après il est lui-même après les simples
il est direct il est concret et tout
d'un coup ils donnent un peu d'âme aux
personnages alors et c'est très
important parce que ce qui va se passer
samedi
personne ne peut en voir la fin personne
ne peut prédire la fin c'est finalement
la première manifestation sociale de
réseaux sociaux qui est unique et où
tout peut arriver et où surtout les
français vont exprimer leur colère mais
leurs doutes leurs doutes d'être plus
pauvre que l'on est et leurs parents et
que leurs enfants soient plus forts
qu'eux mêmes
exactement c'est le plus difficile
problème
camélia macro aura réglé justement on
voulait on voulait voir nous surtout
voilà la colla coup le comportement
télévisuelle des manières à la croix
hier et c'est vrai qu'il ya il a fait
beaucoup de gestes avec les mains avec
les doigts ou lilian mathieu de leur nom
ce que moi je veux dire aussi c'est pas
si clair sur la forme et vous qui êtes à
même de de publicité marketing
c'est le premier président pardon sont
un peu honnête qui est beau et qui est
très beau le but c'est très important
qu'il a tenus là connu moi je suis
sensible une veste et un petit peu
centre est bon d'entamer un âge où la
raison le land avait des grandes lettres
au caramel et m'aideront à l'arrière
questions sur le chat botté il est
agressif dit il dit qu'il ya trois
médailles dans l'ain d'autres dans
l'aisne dans l'énergie il dit au début
de l'année en janvier je vais vous
remettre 4 milliards et j'assume
là dessus on peut lui faire on l'a c'est
bien parce que c'est la porte et on
s'est inversée
mais d'ici là on parle de la forme et
vidéo et vous importants les chenilles
sont sensibles on est tous sensibles il
a une veste à peu cintrée ses deux
premiers rocard avait des baisses trop
large hollande aussi la vie dans les
yeux très bleus la coupe de cheveux
évidemment qu'il est très bon évidemment
déjà content
avec ses mains avec ses doigts regardent
soit vous ne vais pas me mettre à faire
un débat avec le président des états
unis d'amérique
aller vers une armée européenne et donc
construire une vraie capacité de défense
européenne vous voyez des puissances qui
se re militaris et donc pour ce faire
nous ne devons pas dépendre y compris
des états unis c'est pourquoi nous avons
décidé nous français de réinvestir et
donc l'armée c'est aujourd'hui après
l'éducation nationale et cela je veux
aussi le faire au niveau européen avec
lequel on mène les opérations les plus
compliqués c'est ça ce qui coûte
bon ils commencent à baisser il va
continuer moi j'ai pris des engagements
clairs ça d'ailleurs commencé à baisser
le problème qu'ont nos concitoyens mais
voilà donc vous disais qu'il était
boueux unis vrai héros de la division la
télévision c'est ça je l'appelais
virginie vous sait j'adore 50%
c'est le gars est ce le patient s'en
fout grâce lachine euros c'est la
gestuelle et le dit ne comptent que pour
15% à voilà donc alors ceux qui dans
cette émission était assez réussie c'est
que justement il a eu des gestes il
était il a eu des mots d'après les
mousses ont relancé le lendemain par les
médias par la presse et par là dernier
mot virginie oui il a eu des gestes de
quelqu'un qu'il voulait convaincre et
qui essaie de convaincre était très
engagé dans ce qu'il disait moi j'ai
retenu une phrase très important qui
finalement peut-être résume le climat
aujourd'hui en france et je n'ai pas
réussi à réconcilier les français avec
leurs dirigeants
c'est une forme de mea culpa l'étagé
marché lui mais qui traduit bien le
divorce qui existe c'est actuellement
entre emmanuel macron et les français la
veille on va pas faire de politique ici
on s'intéresse à longer télévisuelle
merci oui il dit ça mais que la phrase
c'est mais je vais m'y employer dans les
mois qui viennent et 10 pages échoué
j'ai trouvé qu'il avait l'air très
inquiet je sais pourquoi il inquiet
parce que nicolas hulot n'a pas parlé
depuis la démission du gouvernement qui
parlera jeudi prochain à 21h dans les
actions
les surélever manuel marquez sur tf1 et
pendant ce temps là y'avait gilles
verdez qui était très très et garder sur
s'est vite regardez on vous a fait
regarder s'ils se rencontrent et
emmanuel macron égide rdc qui est une
impatience oui considérer que le
gouvernement a tardé attendu où s'est
trompé sur la stratégie ou les constats
non
[Musique]
mais vous mais vous mais vous étiez le
vomi à vilipender ce programme et vous
devriez être appert qu'il réfléchisse un
peu plus retourner moi je veux plus voir
à gauche que vous avez dit c'est
inadmissible ce qu'ils ont fait c'est
dégueulasse franchement c'est non non ne
riez par ne riez pas l'armée c'est
aujourd'hui le deuxième budget de la
nation est en crise naissent vous mentez
je crois que ce que les françaises et
les français attendent de moi c'est de
ne pas répondre a détruit un peu non [ __ ]
vous c'est la parole à chaque fois tu
réponds pas cher jamais à joindre les
gens que ce sera mon dernier mot c'est
un vaste programme mais il requiert la
mobilisation de toute la nation s'il
vous plaît vous en conjure ne gâchez pas
l'émission non je me retourne et vous
fermez votre gueule alors il n'a pas pas
aller au président la lui parla nicolas
pernikoff qui est un autre président en
brèche le président de france
télévisions voilà sur wilshere il ne se
permettrait pas j'ai des revendeurs qui
s'étonnait que deux fois aux joies du
haut la barre des 10